From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Good morning. This is David Cline from the History Department at Virginia Tech for the Civil Rights History Project of the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
Today we are here in San Diego, California and this project is being recorded for, as I said, for the Civil Rights History Project.
We have with us Guha Shankar of the Library of Congress and behind the camera is John Bishop of Media Generation and UCLA.
Today we have the great pleasure of being with Mr. Mateo Camarillo and I will ask you sir if you could just this the only time that I'll coach you at all today, as if you could introduce yourself in a full sentence I am or my name is and where and when you are bored.
My name is Mateo Camarillo. It's a great honor to be a party to this project because that's what America is all about the contribution of all these elements that make up this great society.
I was born in Mexico in Tijuana which is a adjacent (Tijuana adjacent to San Diego) sharing the same ecosystem with San Diego and I was born the year World War II started in 1941.
So I'm a Mexican citizen by birth, my mother as a US citizen. But during the war she was involved in the war effort working at Convair making planes B-29 bombers and working the tuna factory.
It was large tuna factory especially in Barrio Logan located in Barrio Logan. We lived in Tijuana until 1950 when we immigrated. I have a brother and two sisters and we all immigrated in 1950 and lived in San Diego ever since.
Can you tell me a little bit more about your family background and the role that that played in your life as you sort of started to develop a sense of who you were.
My father was a Mexican by birth. He was from Northern Mexico and Nuevo León. My mother and her family have roots from Mexico. But you know they immigrated in the early beginning of the century.
My mom Rufina was born in Campo which is a community in San Diego. They met in Campo where she lived. They were actually neighbors.
But my father moved back to Mexico in Tijuana and that's why we were born. The four of us, my brother and my two sisters, we were born in Tijuana.
My mother grew up in Campo and she had two brothers that served in World War II and actually died in fighting for our country.
So that's basically you know I've been born you know in coming to this country. Eventually I after graduating from college I volunteered to serve in the armed forces because we're involved in the battles in Southeast Asia and Vietnam and so forth.
And I felt obligated to pay back for what I had earned the opportunities to be here and so I served in the US Army.
So when you first settled in the US as a small child can you tell me about that process of becoming an American living in the US for the first time and speaking English and what the school system was like for a young Spanish speaker at that time.
There didn't exist such a thing as bilingual education. So when we immigrated I was in the second grade in Tijuana and so they gave me a test which obviously was in English and I failed it miserably because I didn't know English.
And all the classes you know were fortunately it was a very small school and the grades were two grades per room. So we would all huddle around and ask in Spanish what did she say the teacher, qué dijo" and among ourselves try to make sense out of what the teacher was saying.
And it was difficult because we didn't know English but most of the students didn't speak English either because it was a farm labor community made up of immigrants.
So how did you survive? How did you move forward?
It was a struggle and we did the best we could. Fortunately I had a teacher who invited me to have a nice drink with her after school and then I realized that teachers were actually human beings.
So just talking about being in the schools as a young student. Initially I thought we were mentally retarded because we couldn't communicate but we eventually learned a few words and were able to.
Especially in the playground where it comes more natural to communicate with English speaking students and that's how we learn just by trial and error sort of speak.
Now did you confront difficulties from the angle students who were there as well?
Initially they learned especially in the playground that we were actually very good and so they wanted us on their team.
So that's how we learned to be able to communicate with each other even though initially there was some animosity but we got over it as we demonstrated we were human beings just like they were.
So what was the sort of racial geography of San Diego at that time in terms of where people lived where things very much separated or not?
Yes, when we immigrated my mother got a job in Mission Valley which is agricultural. Mission Valley is close to the first mission built by Junípero Serra and by the San Diego River.
It was agricultural land and dairy and agricultural and most of the workers were immigrants.
So the transition we had a support system, you know, other immigrants.
So we kind of faced in learning a little bit at a time you know through and I started work at age 10 when we immigrated and in the work environment also spoke you know learned English beyond school.
And so that's how we gradually you know learned English.
It wasn't the other way around English speaking students in Spanish. Now it would have been good though because we both would have two languages and we could communicate freely.
That would take a long time before anything like that was thought of.
How about where you lived in the neighborhood where you lived was a immigrant neighborhood or were there people who had been here a long time what was that neighborhood like?
The neighborhood where your family eventually lived in 10 years ago.
Yeah, we immigrated in 1950 and I was 10 years old and there were in the Mission Valley area there were not immigrants because of the labor required in the farming and dairy industries.
And so that was sort of a safety net to be able to gradually learn English.
And you learn another language by practice. Just like later years I was stationed in Europe and I traveled all over Europe and learned languages of other countries where I visited.
How did I'm interested in how you defined yourselves when you were young in terms of what did you call yourself?
Would you use the term Chicano? Mexican, Mexican American. How did your family or those around you talk about who you were?
Well, we were basically identified as Mexican. Others defined us and we accepted the definition because we were from Mexico and so we were Mexican.
And gradually evolved to Mexican Americans because we were in the United States and so evolved to Mexican American because we were struggling to become successful participants.
And so that was in this great country. The term Chicano evolved several years later. That was not actually was a negative connotation that was more of a slur.
It actually was adopted as a proud term for those that were struggling to gain the same rights as other citizens in this country.
Now in your schooling as at a young age but then into high school were you learning about your own people at all? What was the schooling that you were getting here in the California State System?
No, there was no information about Mexico or Mexicans. It was independent of schools where I stayed connected by visiting Tijuana and other cities in Mexico to continue being connected.
But we transitioned over time to the larger San Diego community which is majority English speaking.
The thing that for me made it easier than terms of transition. I was pretty good in sports and through sports and the playground is where I started developing leadership skills and I was selected in charge of the junior patrols which is the crossing guards so that we control traffic so that other students could,
across the street. So that evolved into plus leadership skills in the playground. And so that actually gave you pride and encouragement that you were just as good as the next person.
So if you could just walk me through the chronology of high school and what you did after high school and your service in the Army.
As I mentioned in elementary school, I was pretty good in the playground and actually in junior high there was a coach that wanted to start a team for cross country runners in junior high.
And he asked me to come out and try and I did and I was pretty good at it. And I was actually the champion of our grade.
And when I graduated and went to high school, I joined the coach asked me to come out and run for the track team and the cross country team. And I did and I later all years I was there.
And so that really was the area where I built self confidence and eventually evolved to be able to learn English because I was very active in sports.
And I let her in and when I graduated from high school, I got scholarships because of my involvement.
And so what happened after high school? Well, as I indicated, I got two scholarships. One was from my alma mater, Herbert Hoover High School. I got a scholarship. And then a second scholarship, I got from the Allied Gardens.
The Allied Gardens was the adjacent community of Allied Gardens where I was there. And so with those two scholarships, I went to college, nobody in my family had ever gone to college. We were even graduated from high school.
So that was new territory. But I was also the comfort of having three jobs. And so I was occupied both in sports and in education and in three different jobs.
So which college did you attend? San Diego State.
Yeah. And I graduated in four years. And that was at the time when the Vietnam War was going on strong. And during that while I was in college, President Kennedy was a commencement speaker in 1962.
And I had been very interested in President Kennedy. He had actually an outreaching into the Hispanic community. They were called Viva Kennedy Clubs Clubs Clubs. And I got involved in the Bivacanity Club in San Diego. And then when it came and gave the very inspirational graduation speech, that even motivated me more to get involved in civic life and various aspects.
I was a member of the CIVIC Engagement Board of Registration, helping others become citizens. I became a citizen at age 21. I was eligible because my mother was a US citizen. I became a naturalized citizen at age 21 where I was eligible to apply. And I applied and I became a citizen. And so I got more. As a citizen became more involved in the civic life of our communities.
So you talk about Kennedy, were there other particular moments that started to point you towards involvement?
Well, that was the entry point to getting involved. And then I was involved in sports. I started getting involved in other aspects of college life. Although I lived at home. But I still was participating in various civic activities.
And basically through voter registration, getting more familiar with how government worked. And the partnership between the citizens and our elected representatives, I got more familiar with that process and have been involved in the civic life of our citizens.
So were there voter registration drives going on in the city?
Yes. Well, the Viva Kennedy Clubs Clubs Club was beginning. And then subsequently I started a voter registration project in San Diego connected to Southwest Council of La Raza, Southwest Voter Registration Education Project.
Can you tell me a little bit about that?
Yes. It was the first multicultural voter registration project in San Diego where we included African Americans, Native Americans, Asian Americans.
Because many of them were not participating. They were either eight not citizens or not involved in the civic life. So we reached out to them to become more broader and more effective because we're all on the same boat.
And we found out that that's a good way to improve our lives and our communities. But we were more successful by including others in similar situations like Asian Americans, African Americans and Native Americans.
So about what year was this? You're working with that?
This is in 1962 from the Kennedy Clubs on. And the reason we got involved with lots of Native Americans, there are 14 Native American tribes in San Diego County. And so the very significant element of our communities.
When you graduate from college, is that when you went into the service?
Yes. Many of my friends actually left the country. They went to Canada or Mexico because they didn't want to. Vietnam was a very unpopular war, especially with young college age folks that were eligible to be drafted.
And they didn't want to be serving that. But I felt obligated to serve to show to demonstrate that I was grateful for the opportunities to participate in their civic life.
And I served, I volunteered in the Army. And there was spinal meningitis in California where the training was. So I was sent to Georgia. And I become more familiar with African Americans being in Georgia, in South Carolina.
So what year is this that you went in? This is in 65.
And this was was this your first experience of the South, the American South? What did they make of you?
None much.
From Los Angeles.
When we finished basic training, we got a three day pass to be able. So we went into Charleston, South Carolina because the closest, which is on the Atlantic coast. And we enjoyed, you know, just like the Pacific, you know, beautiful.
We were in a restaurant. We were waiting to be served. We waited several hours and enjoying the views of the ocean, the Atlantic Ocean and so forth.
And then we finally went looking for the manager and find out what was taking so long to get a meal. And we were informed. There was three of us on this myself, a Mexican American, an African American from Georgia.
And I put a recon because there were a lot of Puerto Ricans in the Army also in the East Coast. So the three of us were waiting and we went. Then I finally, I was asked to go check what was going on. I asked for the manager and asked when I talked to him.
I said, you know, we've been waiting several hours, you know, to be served in, you know, when are we going to be served? Any inform me? You're not even going to be served.
I couldn't believe that. I said, did you run under food? I said, you're not being served. And that was my first experience. It real blatant, you know, discrimination. Three minorities, Mexican American, African American, Puerto Rican. Couldn't be served.
We experienced similar situations in Atlanta. We went to Atlanta one evening. There were night clubs. So we tried to enter. We couldn't enter. They said we had to have a membership card.
We subsequently learned that you buy those in the front door if you're the right at the labor. So that was my experience in the south.
Had you experienced any kind of discrimination like that in California? Not at that level.
So how about in the military itself? How are relations between different ethnic groups?
Well, no, the army were all in it together. No, it was very, very integrated. A large number of, you know, as I say, African Americans, not Mexican Americans, and Puerto Ricans. So, you know, we got along. I mean, because we're in it together. We're on the same side.
And so no, I didn't experience it. And also because I was also involved in sports. We develop a track team. We call ourselves the road rats. And we, so, you know, sports breaks across all their athletic ability.
And so it was pretty good at it. So, you know, we got along very well. And there was no issue with, you know, the different ethnic groups in the army. Because, as I say, you know, we all believe we're on the same side.
How about in basic training? From the, from the, from the sergeants or anything?
No, basic training. One of the things you learn real quick in the army is you take orders. You're in a position to, to argue. So it was the transition in the army, especially basic training. It was pretty, you know, we were in the learning mode.
And so basically, you know, we took orders. You know, we, you know, and so it was, it was not a challenge or difficult. And although the majority of officers were, were Anglo in the majority of the soldiers were minorities.
So when you got your effective life, right, at that time.
So when you got your orders, where were you, where were you sent?
When you got your orders after training, where were you, where were you sent?
Yes. Fortunately, most of the, my peers, fellow soldiers were sent to Vietnam. I was fortunate.
There was too many, you know, which called green or rookie soldiers dying. So they changed the mixture of who was being sent to Vietnam with experienced soldiers more experienced to have better survival rates.
I was fortunate to be sent to Europe as an infill for those that were in Europe being sent to Vietnam. So I was sent to Germany.
And I was, that was a tremendous experience because I'd never been to Europe. And I was in the armored battalion. I was in infantry and training.
But then they, when I sent to Europe, where they needed the backfill was in the armored division. So I was sent to the fourth army.
And I was the training officer for the battalion, the fourth armor battalion. And I did my job as a training officer one week's work in one day.
So they needed to find other things for me to do. And the children of soldiers don't have much stimulation or things to do.
So the most of the Boy Scouts in Europe are dependent children of soldiers. And they've asked me to lead the Boy Scouts of America in Europe and asked me if I would accept that.
I knew nothing about Boy Scouts, but you know, I was willing to learn. And so I was named the Scoutmaster" of Europe, the Transatlantic Council in Europe.
And fortunately, I was, since I was able to do my job in one day for a whole week, I was able to travel all over Europe, taking kids through all the countries in Europe because all the military bases
had Boy Scout facilities. We traveled a little over Europe. My experience in my two years in Europe was very enjoyable because I could do the work very easy and then enjoy, you know, the working with, you know, as a matter of fact, being a Scoutmaster" in working with children and families
was what led me when I got released or released when I finished my two years and came back. I came back to San Diego. And since I had enjoyed working with families, I joined the welfare department to work with, continue working with families in San Diego as a civilian.
So you're back in San Diego and have been hired by the welfare department. Can you tell me a little bit about that position and the issues that we're facing San Diego, and especially Latinos in San Diego at that time?
When I joined the welfare department, I was a rarity. There were very few Spanish-speaking social workers, be Anglo or Mexican or African American, they didn't speak Spanish.
And there was a large number of Spanish-speaking families that applied for services, but were, and they paid taxes just like everybody else, but weren't getting services because there was no workers available that were bilingual.
So that quickly led me to organizing not only within the welfare department, but with other with probation and the Sheriff's Department and other departments, and then outside the county to recruit more people because the need was so.
I had English-speaking social workers like me, but spoken only English, they had a, what's called a caseload, how many families they did, 60. I had 600.
Now, that was totally unfair. I mean, I couldn't service them right. And my job was to try to help them become independent so they could be off public assistance. That was my goal, is to have people be independent and self-sufficient, but they had to know how to apply for a job, you know, what were the job market was, and basically counseling, advising them of how they could succeed.
But you couldn't do it with 600 families, it was just not doable. So I increased my efforts in recruiting and trying to, so I formed an organization because you can't do it by yourself.
So I formed an organization called Trabajadores de la Raza de la Raza, workers for the people. And other social workers throughout the United States were forming Trabajadores de la Raza de la Raza chapters. And so we formed a national organization of Trabajadores de la Raza de la Raza.
And we connected with each other to help each other to build more bilingual social workers, be the Hispanic or Anglo, so that their services could be provided to people that needed the services. So they could become independent and self-sufficient.
Now did that organization work within the city organizations or outside or together with?
Well, the San Diego chapter worked in San Diego, San Diego County, all 18 cities in San Diego, not just one city. And we connected with, you know, other chapters Los Angeles, San Jose, in Texas, San Antonio, Houston, and the East Coast.
So we formed a national and we helped each other, you know, in various cities. And that's how.
But did you work independently of the?
Yes, the federal or city programs or?
Yeah, yeah. You worked with the well federal.
You worked with the well federal.
Within San Diego County.
Okay.
But working with the well-fair department or outside of the city system?
Well, the a large number of the members work within the county because that's who provides has a responsibility of the municipal governments to provide social service.
The city doesn't do it, but we did, you know, connect with city folks. I mean, we needed, you know, recruits and participants that were bilingual.
And, you know, because we did this after hours, you know, we obviously didn't do it as we were getting paid to do our work as social workers.
Okay. So, our profession officers or shares deputies.
So, it's an addition too. So, how did you fund these efforts?
Well, well.
It's taken a lot of funding.
Yes, we did it through membership dues initially.
And then we, you know, I learned, I actually in college, I learned grant writing and I was a community organizer and was able to, you know, develop funding through various, you know, sources of foundations for foundation, government, national and environmental health to be able to supplement whatever we could do privately.
And one of the initial successful efforts that we did in San Diego is that we met with public officials and demanded that there be more bilingual social as a matter of fact, as an incentive to get more bilingual social workers.
We were very successful in convincing elected officials, the county board supervisors, for example, to pay a bonus on top of the salary of 10% of the salary as a bonus for those that spoke Spanish because they were actually doing twice the work because they spoke to languages.
And we convinced them of the need and the reward for doing, you know, twice the work.
And that passed at the county level. With that success, we approached the city and did the same thing and got a bilingual pay bonus for city workers.
And then we went to the largest employer in San Diego at that time. We're talking about the early 1970s was the utility, San Diego Gas and Electric Company.
And we convinced the board of directors of SDG and E, San Diego Gas and Electric to pay a bonus and got that instituted. So the three largest employers in San Diego, the city of San Diego, the county of San Diego and the utility company SDG,
were adopted bilingual paying. And that led me to work with the state legislature with African-American and Hispanic, Richard Alatorre for Los Angeles and Mervyn Dymally, was actually from the Dominican Republic, but was, you know, resident in California.
And those two, I worked together, we established a state bilingual pay program in the late 1970s. And so we were able to apply statewide because it just common sense.
And that's how we were able to be very successful. And then those successes led us to other efforts to try to help, you know, the underserved communities.
So what were the big issues in the 70s that you were dealing with in trying to address the major issues?
The major issues is being treated equally. And the manifestation of how unfairness occurred was pretty obvious.
The lack of services, for example, in the language that people understood. And try to develop, you know, bilingual programs so that there could be a transition in terms of Spanish speakers.
So we worked on all those fronts. And it took a while. For example, the Grand Jury, the county of San Diego, they changed every year, you know, who the jurors are.
And when you're the Grand Jury investigated and came up with the conclusion that bilingual education, as we were starting it, was on American.
And that's so angered, you know, Spanish speakers. Here we're trying to, you know, through bilingual education, be able to participate.
And they're talking as un-American because we're trying to learn English using bilingual education. So we formed an ad hoc committee of 15 different organizations and demanded that the Grand Jury be abolished.
Or the jurors be replaced because how could we be un-American by trying to participate in America by the language, you know, bilingual as a transition to English.
And so we faced different struggles over time, but, you know, eventually, you know, we were successful.
How about other issues that you talk about education, what about employment, housing, healthcare, where these all issues that we're facing folks in the 70s?
Especially employment. I mean, that's basic in which affects the other issues of affordability of health or, as a matter of fact, we expanded, I've mentioned about bilingual services.
And so the other is that there were no, no, no, no, food programs for those that, you know, were either homeless or low income that could make ends meet.
And so we eventually convinced the board of supervisors through Trabajadores de la Vasa to adopt a food program.
So the county of the 58 counties in California was the only one that did not have a food program.
And so we convinced them to adopt a food program starting with the poorest neighborhood in San Diego County, San Ysidro right on the border between San Diego and Mexico and Tijuana.
And so we were successful through the San Ysidro Women's Club and others to convince the board of supervisors to adopt, you know, a food program.
And that was the beginning of, you know, broader services available to Spanish speakers.
And then we did the same thing in labor force in terms of trying to open up jobs for, we actually had to sue the county of San Diego.
I was selected the executive director of the Chicano Federation, which is an umbrella organization for Spanish-speaking organizations in San Diego.
And as the executive director, when, you know, obviously made the papers and people, counts and stream of employees came to me to my office, asked for help because they were facing such, such.
So much discrimination in the job market.
And the biggest group were coming were county employees.
And so, you know, I basically took their information and having been a county employee, I was very familiar with, you know, county government and county employment.
And I informed them that we could, we'd have to take legal action.
However, you know, they risked the possibility of losing their job if, you know, there was litigation involved.
And so I had to inform them that that was a possibility.
But yet they wanted justice and they kept, they wanted to go forward.
At that time, this, this is 1974. At that time, there were six Latino attorneys in town.
So I notified all six to meet with at our office because I had so many cases that demanded fairness.
And I shared with them the information because I had permission to do that.
And I let them know that as I indicated that if we move forward with litigation that they could lose their job.
They agreed to go forward. We went forward.
And through the, and the civil rights that passed equal opportunity employment became federal law.
And under those laws, we sued the county of San Diego.
It took a long time to get justice.
And as a matter of fact, there's a long-ghost lasting civil rights case in the history of the United States.
But we went and opened up the opportunities at the county, which set the example where we could do the same at the city in the SDGE and other in the private sector.
And that's how we did in terms of increasing employment opportunities.
And the longest lasting in terms of the lawsuit. You said the longest lasting case in terms of the suit.
That's correct. Yeah. Because it was so complicated.
We actually added other groups because they came to us. African Americans came to us.
We added African Americans. Asian Americans came to us. We added Asian Americans.
Filipinos. So we had Mexican Americans, African Americans, Filipinos, Asian Americans.
All the minority groups in San Diego County, in the under our case.
And that's what it took a long time because it was complicated. It included all these groups that we won.
And what did you win? What changed?
The county, the employers starting with the county had to employ minorities.
At the time, before that we won, before the case was filed 67% of all Hispanics that applied for employment were turned down.
We won the right to have opportunities for people applying for jobs. 67% of applicants be ineligible.
So there were artificial barriers that had to come down. That's what we won.
And we won the bill and removal of barriers and equal opportunity. That's what we won.
And people got jobs. Right. That's what we won. And we won beyond the county.
We also did that with the city and private sector.
And that, it only was possible because we had such a broad base, such a broad support.
No one could do that by themselves or even just one single group. I mean, we're all part of the same family.
We're all part of the same situation and experiencing the same kinds of discrimination, if you will, or lack of opportunity.
But jobs are important and basic to the actual survival. And people deserve a right to work, but they're qualified. And they were.
Absolutely. And so that was very, very rewarding to be able to succeed like that.
So it's going to ask, we're already talking about this with the case and the coalitions, right, with other groups.
Can you talk more about the need for that and what other coalitions you created at that time?
Another example of working with others.
When President Nixon was running for re-election, he promoted a program called General Revenue Sharing, which was providing funds to cities and counties with no strings attached.
They could do whatever with those funds, General Revenue Sharing.
Well, we were grateful that that was, however we were concerned since local government, city and county, were not very flexible in terms of serving all the populations, especially under served communities.
So we formed a coalition led by the Chicano Federation, I would not be the executive director.
And the chairman of the board, Dr. Alfredo Velasco, and I, and there was an Anglo coalition, like the Chicano Federation, that had multiple service delivery organizations under it.
We teamed up, the Community Congress, which is primarily Anglo.
And that was the time of the hippie movement of the beach community and, you know, young, disenfranchised Anglos.
So we had a lot in common.
And so we joined forces and we traveled to Washington, the leaders of the two coalitions, went to Washington to find out more about the intent of Congress.
And, you know, how it was supposed to work.
And it was basically to serve low-income communities.
But that's not the way, you know, it was going to be implemented based on what we already knew.
And initially started out, the city wanted to serve fund its own pet projects, including units of the city, of the government.
And we argued that that was not the intent of Congress.
It was to eliminate poverty and discrimination.
So we got all the social service agencies in San Diego, family service, Catholic services, social services, the city and county services.
And the agency's funded as well as United Way as a private agency's informed, you know, an alarming of civilian citizens and challenged the city in the county.
And the governments that were using it internally, that's not the intent of Congress.
And they tried to redefine, you know, who would be eligible, who was a senior citizen, who was poor.
Those who are already defined in federal law, the Older Americans Act, they said, define who was a senior.
They were empowered, defined, who was poor or low-income.
So we challenged them, and they wouldn't accept that. So we sued them, and won.
And basically they had a lot of straight line.
And we were able to get the first year, a little over $5 million for the community organizations by passing local government.
And then next year we got a little over $6 million, you know.
So that working together was a great experience in terms of being able to provide for the needs of low-income seniors and so forth that was not government controlled or defined by government as to who was poor and who was a senior.
You know, that's already defined at the federal level. And so we won those battles.
And it was very rewarding because that led to, you know, other battles to be able to provide for the needs of the underserved.
Now, were you aware or in touch with other Latino organizations around here, but maybe in Los Angeles or in other places as well?
I'm just curious what in terms of the Chicano or Latino communities, what kinds of ways you were involved with one another?
Yes. And the, as I mentioned, you know, we formed Trabajadores in San Diego.
And there were other chapters were being developed in other cities, Los Angeles, San Jose, Houston, New York, Denver.
And so we connected, you know, we kept communication with the other chapters and we were able to each share, you know, and we learned from each other.
And that encouraged us to move on. And the strongest group was the Spanish-speaking organizations because that was the largest ethnic group at that time.
And it still is, even more so. And the concept Chicano became more in common use. And as a matter of fact, when I left the faculty at San Diego State, I joined the staff of the Chicano Federation, which is the first Spanish-speaking organization in San Diego County that was multiple discipline and included all organizations,
and that was the executive director of the Chicano Federation. And through that organization as well as through Trabajadores de la Raza, the La Raza, I was an officer of that.
We connected with, you know, other organizations and other in the different cities. And we worked together as a matter of fact, the strongest chapter in the Indigenous San Diego was San Jose, Santa Clara County.
And they were working through education and to try to start a school of social work to prepare bilingual social workers. And they recruited me to join the faculty to start the school of social work at San Jose.
So, not only was I in communication, I was recruited. And I joined the faculty at San Jose State because of Trabajadores de la Raza La Raza. They asked me, you know, to help and start the school of social work.
So, when were you at San Diego State and when were you at San Jose?
When I got out of the army, you know, as I say, I was eligible for the GI educational bill of rights to be able to get, you know, two years of further education.
So, I went to San Diego State on the GI bill to get a master's degree. And, but during that time, I was working at the county. So, I was, you know, I've always did multiple jobs at the same time.
And, well, I was a student in the school of social work getting my master's degree. This is when I was working for the county and developing Trabajadores de la Raza La Raza and so forth.
When I graduated with a master's degree in social work and community organizing was my specialty. I even trained with Saul Alinsky, who was the greatest organizer in terms of, he trained César Chávez, he trained Barack Obama, he trained the founders of the National Council of La Raza.
And so, I applied for a Ford Foundation Fellowship to go to Chicago to train under Saul Alinsky and community organizing and joined the faculty of San Jose to train organizers.
And so, that was, I left San Diego State when I graduated and went to San Jose to be the second in command as the coordinator for field instruction, which is 50% of the time as students in graduate school in schools of social work.
And, it had a pleasant two-year experience of getting that school off the ground and seeing, you know, the next generation of young leaders, you know, coming out of graduate schools.
At that time, there were very few, you know, trained social workers with a master's degree in the whole country. And, so that experience was very, and I recruited to, on the faculty,
one of the founders of the National Council of La Raza, Herman Gallegos, who was originally from San Francisco, well, he was born in San Jose, in Santa Clara, in the largest body of California, Sal Si Puedes, where César Chávez, they grew up together, César Chávez and Herman Gallegos.
And, I asked Herman to join me on the faculty, which he did, after he had founded the National Council of La Raza.
And, Herman, I recruited him because he had worked with many foundations, the Ford Foundation, Rockefeller Foundation.
And, he knew about accessing capital, especially in the private sector. And, as a new school, we needed more than just state funding.
So, you know, that was the other reason, because he was a good organizer, and we needed some help in identifying source of funding to be able to do what we wanted to do, because the state wouldn't fund what we were trying to do, as a normal course of thing.
And, so we were very successful, because of the team that we put together, including Herman Gallegos.
I wanted to ask slightly related, maybe a little bit different about, but again, with other groups that you may have worked with.
And, you know, there obviously there's different approaches in activism, you know, sort of along a spectrum from radical revolutionary to all the way across to sort of working within the system.
And, I'm wondering if you worked with other groups that had different approaches and how that went. And, I know, I'm thinking of the Brown Berets, who started in California.
Did you work with labor unions? Did you ever have, you know, conflicts or good working relations with groups that had a slightly different approach?
Some who wanted revolution now, for example, or, you know, I wonder if you could comment on that.
Yes. Actually, all of the above. When I was the executive director of the Chicano Federation, we were countywide. And, we worked with all those groups.
As a matter of fact, my offices were under the San Diego-Coronado Bridge. And, we worked with grassroots in Chicano Park and led by my sister Tomasa Camarillo, Camarillo, who was elected chairman of an organization called Chicano.
She called a park steering committee. And, they were headquartered in Chicano Park and they actually were promised the community, Hispanic community, Spanish speaking community was promised by the city that there'd be a park under the bridge.
Well, it turned out that promise they were reneging and they were going to put a highway patrol station because it was a state land under the bridge. The bridge is state-funded.
And so the landowner was state and they were going to put a highway patrol. To us, you know, highway patrol, police department, sheriff there, the police.
And, not very friendly in various ways. And, I'll give you a couple of examples. But, at that point, they physically led by my sister took over the land under the bridge and occupied it.
And, with picks and shovels, developed a park. Chicano Park. There was no parks and rec department or any city involvement.
So, we physically, you know, led by my sister, Tomasa Camarillo, who's still the president of Chicano Park steering committee to this day.
And, many of the members of this company were artists. And, they saw this great surfaces, the pillars, and they decided, hey, you know, we're going to beautify these raw cement pillars.
That was the birth of the mural movement. And, you now drive and you see all the pillars decorated with mural movement, which is the history of the Chicano movement.
My offices, when I was director, it's kind of right there under the bridge. It was a bill with federal funds. And, rather than having highway patrol, we had this facility with federal funds. And, we housed multiple social services.
Well, for rides, Brown Berets, Pinto Union Union, Pinto Union in Spanish, are ex-cons.
The various, we had, we recruited government agencies and private agencies like human resources from the state of California to have an office there for employment, information on jobs and counseling.
We had the welfare department, provide social workers, and we had social services provided. And, we did a demonstration project how social service ought to be dealt in a more humane and multicultural way.
And so, we did that with mental health also, because the mental health approaches as people are crazy or have a deficit mental health, you know, that's not the way to approach it.
We did a demonstration project of how it should be done. And, as I said, we housed all various government, private, and volunteer organizations such as the Pinto Union Union, such as the Brown Berets.
Those were our private. And, we all got along because we were in the same boat. We just had different ways of doing it. And, but we helped each other.
For example, one of the first persons to visit me when I was selected executive director of the Chican version was the change police chiefs.
And, it was Bill Kolender was selected and I testified in the selection in support because he was a human being. He was Jewish by background, but, you know, he knew the experience of discrimination.
And, as soon as I was selected, he called me and wanted to meet. And so, I met with him. And, we agreed we would meet on a regular basis, we changed phone numbers. And, we had direct contact, didn't have to go through intermediate areas or whatever.
So, we could solve problems directly. And, just a couple of examples. One of them is hot pursuit. Hot pursuit of police running to our building, which had welfare rights, women, senior citizens, women, various services to the people.
And, you can't have police running through your building when trying to provide services to people. That just scares the heck out of people. And, I picked up the phone and told the chief of police that was unacceptable.
Without riots, without any bullying, that ceased. Why? Because, we went to lunch and we agreed that we, you know, meet regularly and we have access to each other. Be a phone.
The setting happened with the mayor. The mayor at that time was Pete Wilson. We met exchange phone numbers and agreed to pick up the phone whenever we want to talk. And, we'd meet every three months on a regular basis.
Those kinds of lines of communication help. That's why you didn't find riots in San Diego, like you had in Watts, LA or Detroit, various other cities throughout the country.
In my opinion is because we could pick up the phone and talk to people that could solve if you had a dispute or a quarrel. Another example is one evening, one Sunday evening, the police department has different divisions, you know.
The Northern Division, which covers La Jolla and the more affluent communities in the north, two officers that finish the shift at 2 a.m. in the morning decided that Sunday that they would have some fun.
The shift they put on blank gloves went to Barrio Logan. In Barrio Logan was the headquarters, two blocks from my office. The largest low rider car club in San Diego, Brown Image.
The town agent members came to my office that morning, Monday morning, to let me know what had happened at 2 a.m. at their headquarters. The police came and saw the lights that were working on their cars, them and their girlfriends.
They had their headquarters on Logan Avenue and the police decided to beat the heck out and they did not only the men but the women. And then we're so angry, they came to me and they said, hell to pay. This is what happened.
We immediately got on the phone called the mayor Pete Wilson, the chief of police Bill Coler, and says, you better get your ass down here before 5 o'clock.
So, this is going to be a meeting with Brown Image. This is what happened. And your presence is required by 5 o'clock.
5 o'clock we had Mayor Pete Wilson, Bill Kolender, and the city manager.
There were 500 low riders and their supporters and their friends. And so I just for them to explain what had happened.
Brown Image leaders spoke about what had happened. There was no denial from the police department. But they were readily apologizing.
The chief of police apologized and never happened again. The mayor, this will never happen again. The city manager, we wanted better relations that would not happen.
The fact that we could communicate, saved a riot in San Diego.
Other very disturbing acts by the police was, this is the high anti-immigrant experience and we're right next to two. One of Mexico.
The police that authorized taxi cab drivers to take Mexican looking folks to immigration.
That came to my attention from residents in San Ysidro. I call Bill Coler, says, that's unacceptable. Immediately ceased.
Those things wouldn't have happened if I couldn't pick up the phone and talk to somebody that could solve the problem.
And that's one of the differences of the city's experience versus other cities where there wasn't that kind of communication.
So yes, I did deal with folks that had different lifestyles and different methods of getting justice.
But we got along because we could solve problems. And I didn't object to how they did it. I mean, that's none of my business.
And they didn't object. It's a matter of they supported what I was doing. And so that was a very rewarding experience to be able to solve problems without violence.
But we got justice.
What do you think those individuals you mentioned, Mayor Pete Wilson and the police chief? What do you think that they were amenable to talking with you and actually open in a way that many elected officials in other places have not been something in the air of San Diego.
The largest minority group by far were Hispanics, Latinos, Mexican Americans.
That's the power of the vote.
And the number is very significant. They had to pay attention. And the doors were not opening. And when people get frustrated because there aren't opportunities, things could go sideways.
Public officials are stupid. They may be prejudice, but they're not stupid.
They would rather have peaceful resolutions, even if it's on their terms, but at least a solution that didn't include violence.
Because somebody's going to get hurt and maybe be them. And so that's, I give them a lot of credit for having come in sense. And I think that that's really why we were able to solve problems without violence.
Now, the, that is not to say that we wiped away discrimination or differential treatment. But you know, we worked at it.
We worked at it through the system, through litigation, through negotiations, through mediation. I mean, that's an avenue that's available. And we try that first.
In our case, we were successful and it worked.
Were there times when taking to the streets was necessary as well? And marches or demonstrations or...
Well, marches, yes. I mean, I even joined in some of those marches. César Chávez, you know, came to San Diego and, you know, I met with them and so forth.
And we joined the boycott. That was marches in the streets and, and, and grocery stores. And so, yeah, you, you do demonstrations like that, but they're non-violent in terms of, you know, attacking private property or private city.
But yeah, sometimes you have to demonstrate publicly, you know, the, the, the, the wrongs that exist to try to correct them and bring attention from the broader community.
And we feel that the, the broader community is, for a minute, you know, they just need information of what's going on.
And that was, you know, our belief and that's what we did.
Fantastic. Yeah.
Let me ask you when you were doing this work and as executive director of the Chicano Federation, was that paying your salary or were you earning money in other ways?
How, how were you keeping the bills paid for yourself?
Yes, I, that, I always paid a salary. I was the exact, I was, we had a staff.
And obviously the executive directors, they hit the staff. And, and I hired other people. I mean, so I didn't did it by myself, you know.
And I had a very supportive, uh, board of directors. The, the federation was unique in that the board of directors were leaders of other organizations.
And so the federation was, that's what it was, a federation of organizations. And so when the federation spoke, it was speaking for all of the Spanish-speaking organizations in town, in the county.
And so it was pretty well respected. And, and we used nonviolent ways, but we also used the, the political system.
We knew how that worked. And, uh, we also, in addition to, you know, my salary and working with others, we also raised money through a PAC, political action committee, to help elect resources.
And, uh, we had to make that, responsible and responsive public officials. So we, we, we, uh, participated to try to change a system both externally and internally.
And, and try to enlighten. And, I met with all of the public officials, the heading up, municipal governments, uh, county board supervisors, there's five supervisors in the county.
And, uh, we, we, we, we didn't have enough registered voters, uh, to elect Hispanics. So, uh, we formed advisory commissions and boards for all the elected officials, may be the same.
And, uh, we had the official, mayors, board supervisors, board commission, um, state assembly members. So that we could be heard. We had input into the public officials, even though we didn't have Latino elected officials.
And, uh, we only been in the city of San Diego, for example, uh, two Latino city council people serving in any one time. And, uh, we haven't had any Latinos on the county board of supervisors.
So we had to have a different avenue to be able to communicate and influence, you know, good government. And that's what we did through organizations.
Now, how long will you executive director of the Federation?
I was there until, uh, 1976 when, you know, after having sued, you know, the city, the state, the county, uh, you know, I'm not a fool. I knew that at some point, the, the old saying don't bite the hand that feeds you.
Well, we were getting government grants. We were getting private money. But, you know, by suing them, that didn't make them very happy.
So I knew that, you know, that was short lived if I wanted to continue challenging wrongness, things that were not quite correct.
That I had to have my own private source of income. So in 1976, I chose to go into the private sector. And, uh, I did research as to, you know, I knew nothing about running a business.
The, the, what I had experiences is selling newspapers, chewing gum, um, picking up recycle materials that could be recycled. That was my experience, shining shoes.
That was my experience in the private sector. Um, so I had to learn more about, uh, how to earn living, a better living than shining shoes.
And the number one industry as I did my research was the food industry. And within the food industry for people like me, the new zero about how to earn a business, I decided that franchising was the way,
was the way to learn because you, you, you are actually implementing a method, a system that already is successful. And the most successful within the food and franchising business was McDonald's.
So I focused on McDonald's, even though I knew the founder, Jack in the box, friend of mine, the silverman. As a matter of fact, I have a picture with him, you know, where he stole my hat.
And he's wearing it and I'm making phone of him stealing my hat. So we were friends. But that was a regional chain, small chain, not nothing compared to McDonald's. So I decided to apply for a franchise for McDonald's.
They turned me down twice, said I was in qualified. I was in agreeable and accepting their turn down. I visited existing franchisees and I looked at this as, I can do a better job than they're doing. Why am I?
So the third time I asked the regional manager McDonald's for a meeting and I said, I'm bringing some guests.
I invited the US congressman from this area, the city councilman from this area, board supervisors from this area, state assemblyman from this area, basically the elected officials who I knew because I'd been dealing with him to this meeting.
With a regional manager, knowing that restaurants need over a dozen government permits, sound for the drive-through, signage, lighting, size, parking, health, over a dozen different requirements interfacing with government.
So who better to have than representatives of the people that even McDonald's has to deal with? And at the start of the meeting, the general manager's name is Dean, Dean Kennerberg.
I said, Dean, before we start, I'd like to introduce the people around here so that you know who you're talking to. So I went by each public official representing him about Philatir's chair.
And so I said, would you say one simple question. Could you explain to these good folks why I'm not qualified to be in McDonald's franchise scene?
Who said you're not qualified? You start tomorrow. That's what I got into business. The rest is history.
From there, I've been stopped. I've got to apply for radio stations. I own half a dozen radio stations. I own other restaurants. I started other businesses.
I've been stopped at the Aztec Nut and Bolt marketing promotional companies. I've been incorporated over a dozen nonprofits and over a dozen for profit.
Basically, be versatile" is you don't put all your eggs in one basket. So I got involved. But the initial start in business was the McDonald's franchise scene.
It's a matter of fact, but I continue my civic involvement. As a matter of fact, I had more leverage and more influence. The Secretary of State for the State of California came to me, March Fong Eu.
She wanted to do a statewide voter registration project and asked me if she wanted to have the private sector participate. I agreed with the Secretary of State to offer free french fries and talk to my fellow frenchisies, other frenchisies to participate.
We gave free french fries to people that showed that they had voted and with that little button. I subsequently by people that were sort of losers accused of trying to influence elections, which is illegal, obviously.
I was rewarding people for voting. I didn't tell them how to vote. That's not my job. My job was to try to increase voter participation. That's what I did.
I had to defend myself, but it was very rewarding to be able to gain in a statewide project with the government, with the Secretary of State, to get more people, and that's one of the things that is a barrier for participation of underserved communities, Hispanic, African-American, immigrants.
They're not all that familiar and don't have the experience in their own countries. This country is great by it. That's those opportunities. But information doesn't flow very easily. That was my job, to get people informed and get them to participate. It's still a job. We got a ways to go.
Can you tell me about the radio stations, their bilingual radio stations? Can you tell me about what got you involved in the power of radio?
The reason I wanted to own radio stations is because information is freedom. The ability to communicate with the people that are impacted by governmental and private decisions is through information, which is not readily available.
In San Diego, there were no Spanish-language stations to inform Spanish speakers. Those few signals that reached San Diego were from Mexico, from Tijuana.
Tijuana is not interested in informing residents of San Diego about city council meetings, school board meetings, information about San Diego. There were a couple also signals from Los Angeles. But that information is about Los Angeles.
Spanish-speaking populations, not knowing what was going on. There were no Spanish-language newspapers. There were small communities, two or three Spanish, but there were small and limited in terms of getting the word out. There's nothing like real-time information rather than history that happened last week.
That's why I wanted to own a radio station to be able to provide information real-time because information is power. You cannot remain in the closet or ignorant without knowing what opportunities exist and how to get yourself informed to take advantage of opportunities.
That's the reason I wanted to start a radio station and learn about how to do businesses through McDonald's. McDonald's is one of the biggest users of radio and television through every French IC dedicates, is required by French IC agreement, to spend 4% of all gross income for advertising radio and television and so forth.
So I knew both as a user and a buyer about the radio station business. So I applied in 1980. Ronald Reagan was president and under his orders, they deregulated the airwaves, the frequencies that were available.
For example, Ronald Reagan was a sports announcer for the Chicago Cubs and the Des Moines, Iowa for station 1040. There was only one station in the whole country at 1040. There was no way that a signal at 1040 could reach the West Coast. There was no 1040 on the West Coast.
The regulation meant that there was a 1040 signal available on the West Coast. I applied for it as did a whole bunch of other people. So I was competing with people from San Francisco, Los Angeles, San Diego, but I won because I was committed and dedicated.
I formed a company, a team, multicultural, Quetzal, bilingual communications. And the purpose of Quetzal is because that's Aztec, Arutz, and it's the bird.
What better way to demonstrate going over the air as a bird? Quetzal. Quetzal and bilingual communications. That was the company that we formed.
It took over 10 years, struggling, fighting off other competitors and other applicants, but we prevailed. They took a lot of money and it took a lot of time.
But once we got that one, and I, with other partners, was able to leverage and go up the state in California, half a dozen in other cities in California to form radio stations, other companies to be able to do that.
And we connected them by satellite so that we could, by economy, a scale, be, enjoy better success. But we were able to give you one example.
In Barrio Logan, there's a lot of pollution because of the Bay, and there was no community planning group to have regulations about what toxic.
There were junkyards next to houses, rodents infested, polluting companies, the tuna factory, Monsanto, harvest at seaweed, and a byproduct with toxic gas. All of that.
And the Port Commission, which controls the Thailand on the [San Diego] Bay, and Barrio Logan is right on the Bay, would call me to ask that we run public service announcements when they were going to be releasing toxic gases that would float over Barrio Logan.
So obviously as a public service, I did that. And unfortunately, it was to prevent a negative, but the positive was getting information out that was non-commercial. I mean, we didn't get paid for public service announcements.
We did it because it was a service. And we started this station in the company because we wanted to serve. And fortunately, we were willing, I mean, money to be able to succeed and continue. But I've dedicated my life to public service.
Even in the private sector, as I told you, the voter registration, I didn't get paid to do voter registration or give away product like trend tries. I did it because there was a public service. I mean, I believe it. That's, I was fortunate that I'd be able to do that because that's really what helped me along as others extending my hand and letting helping out.
So I truly believe that that's what America is about is trying to help your fellow man. And if you can help, why not? I mean, that's how many dollars can you spend? How many meals can you eat? How many houses can you live in? How many cars can you drive? I mean, you got a hell, you're fellow brother to the extent you can. And that's what I've done in all my life. That's what I'm about.
And what I hear you saying what I've picked up on in our conversation is this love for what is possible here, but also a need to apply pressure to keep that possibility open for others. Did I get that about right?
That's correct. And you see it in various ways. As I mentioned, you know, in terms of, you know, elected officials that are supposed to represent the people, well, they represent the voters that vote.
And we needed to change that. We needed to influence public officials by common sense approaches of showing them where discrepancies exist in terms of, you know, public services, public access, public policy.
There wasn't fair because it wasn't representing. There were just representing people that voted. I mean, that's, but there were other people that needed, you know, their attention and their services and public laws like bilingual education, like bilingual pay, things that people that voted for them were not going to be advocating.
So we learned it took pressure. And some of that pressure also was, you know, softened by raising money, like through political action committees to add a little bit of sugar to the conversation.
When I was a McDonald's, I organized with other McDonald franchisees, a political action committee. It's called MacPack to influence or to raise money to contribute.
I met with, you know, governors of the state of California, contributed significantly to the campaign of Jerry Brown, when he first ran in the 70s.
Gray Davis, Cruz Bustamante, and so forth.
Jerry Brown, whenever there was a judicial position open, the reason they called me, it's because I contributed through the Golden 500, privately outside of McDonald's.
We also had Hispanic based Golden, and we had chapters throughout San Diego, Los Angeles, San Francisco, Sacramento, et cetera.
And we taxed ourselves. As a matter of fact, the membership was $500. And we raised other monies. And so, and we contributed, for example, to the first one when we started, Jerry Brown was running for governor.
He was dating Hispanic as a matter of fact, Linda Ronstadt. And so he was sympathetic, and so we influenced that a little bit more. And so whenever he got it, when he got elected, and there was a judicial opening in San Diego, I'd get a phone call.
And once it was opening for six judges, and he says, do you have any recommendations? I nominated all six judges, all lawyers in San Diego, Hispanic, and they all got appointed judges six all the one time, because there was, in others, he appointed me to a board that dealt with the retirement money, pension funds.
And so we made recommendations on how that should be more adequately distributed, you know, as it's earning returns until people have to use it when they retire.
And so, we're involved, you know, it's a two way street, you know, you help them, and they help you. And, but you get more attention when you, they feel that you contributed to them getting elected.
And it's been that way, not only with the governor, I did it with Pete Wilson, who was actually hostile to Hispanics when he was governor of California, with the anti immigrant resolution.
And never since that over 20 years ago, there has not been a Republican elected officer in the state of California, run statewide, be it governor, be it senator, there hasn't been one Republican with exception of one, Arnold Schwarzenegger, who was movie star, well known.
And he employed his nanny, who was a Mexican, so he employed Hispanics. Of course, there were. The point is he was very, that hostility remains to this day, and it's unfortunate for the Republicans that they're taking such a beating in California.
But that's, you have to be responsive to the electorate.
So, do you, has the number of Hispanic registered voters gone, gone up in the time that you've been working on these issues?
I'm pleased to say yes. However, we got a long ways to go. We have a long ways to go. It's because of say, information doesn't flow very easily.
And, and some people that immigrate from countries where there's dictators and people, the democracy isn't as wide open or high corruption, they're not familiar or willing to participate because it's, they don't see, they see the cards stacked against them. They don't participate.
And so it takes a little bit of, you know, reeducation sort of speak of what the democratic process is all about.
Because although their democratic society came from, they're not really in practice, you know, that democratic.
Have the public schools changed in terms of educating Latinos since you were a child here in San Diego?
Definitely, not to the extent they ought to, as you can see by the evidence, over 50% of Hispanics entering public school or Hispanic.
Yet, the graduation rate is horrific. Why is that? It's still got a way to go. It's changed, yes. The research of things is bilingual education, which at least provides a starting point where they could start learning, you know, as in transition, you know, from their native language to English.
But it takes time. Language is not that easy for some folks. And there's also in California a movement to have multicultural curriculum so that they're learning about different cultures, especially their own.
So the Southwest was Mexican for years, centuries. The reminds me of a story that the, when I was in Europe and heard all the different languages spoken in the same country.
But the language is, it surprises me that there's a debate that English should be the only language, the official language, while other countries and other, they're enriched by being multilingual and it's a struggle to have it here.
And the sign of an educated person is knowing about other cultures and languages. When I was going to college, I studied about, I was fortunate to have great teachers. And my, my, our teacher, for example, was an expert on the Aztecs, the Mayans, the Toltecs, the Chichimecs and their art and culture.
And so I named companies after Aztec leaders. Quetzal is the God, one of the gods of the Aztecs.
Quinto Sol, the fifth son is the world we're in today. I named one of my companies, Aztlán. Aztlán is the Southwest part where the Aztecs originated and they migrated until they got to Mexico City.
My name companies Aztec, Aztec, none both. And people ask me why? And I says, that's a sign of educated person. You know, I studied about the Greeks as many college students, state curriculum, study about other cultures.
That's a sign of an educated person. Why do you play down and call it racism or discrimination when you promote, you know, other cultures, you know, that deserve respect and recognition?
That's a sign of an educated person, not an ignorant or prejudice person. And so that's why I promoted and keep promoting multiculturalism. Because, you know, that's a sign that you understand. You know, we're all connected from, you, as a matter of fact, you asked about La Raza and Chícanos.
During the Mexican Revolution, one of the members of the Revolution was an educator José Vasconcelos. José Vasconcelos wrote a book right after the war, the Mexican Revolution called La Raza Cósmica, the Cosmic Race.
And that's where the concept La Raza comes from. And one of the first national organizations I was asked invited to join was the National Council of La Raza, which is the most prominent Latino national organization.
And I served the maximum terms. And during that time, you know, I worked with President Ronald Reagan. He was in the 80s. And we worked with Sen. Orrin Hatch, Republican, and Sen. Edward "Ted" Kennedy, Democrat, and Reagan's presidential delegates to, in the National Council of La Raza, board and staff,
to develop immigration reform. And that passed, signed by Ronald Reagan. Ericka was called immigration reform. Some people call it amnesty. It was actually a way to pardon and legalize people already here fully employed and contributing to the building of America.
But yet, people say we shouldn't be doing that. We're a country of immigrants. And why not? You know, let people that are working here contributing to build their country greater, be able to live here without being scared or being deported.
They're already here working in when I just legalize the situation and acknowledge that that's the fact. And so I've worked that, but I didn't do it by myself. I did it with others because that's how you get things done is working together.
And I'm proud of having been able to make achievements working with in the state of California, the most influential multicultural organization is the Greenlining Institute. It started on housing, green lining, the opposite of red lining, which is done by insurance companies and real estate industry to limit access to funding to buy a house.
Through banks and lending institutions to green lining to be able to do a way of mitigating against red lining. And that organization is led by African Americans, Asian Americans, Latinos, and statewide.
And I was the delegate from San Diego to the Green Lines board of directors and served in that capacity over 20 years. And we worked on banks, insurance industry, telephone industry, utilities to open up.
Green Line opportunities for underserved populations. And under that role, I was asked by the Public Utilities Commission to chair the deregulation of the telephone industry in California. And I was chairman for that for 10 years.
And we developed a citizens board that reported to the Public Utilities Commission. And we provided services and 10 languages for all telephone, wire and wireless companies in California.
And that's an example of doing something with others, multicultural groups in the state of California, to be able to have fairness for underserved populations. That's just one example.
Can you tell us a little bit too about your own involvement in electoral politics as an elected official yourself?
I have one opinion of the response to immigrants.
You ran for office yourself. Could you tell us a little bit about that? And then we will get to that subject.
And I run the first time I ran for public office with school board because education is key. And there has never been or had been today, there is one Hispanic on the school board.
And there was one. When I ran, there were none. And there had never had been. The reason why is because the electoral process to get elected was district wide.
And that's why we work to change that system so that you run by districts in neighborhoods closer to the schools and the communities where the voters are that needed the services of the public officials.
But that didn't exist when I ran. I had to run district wide, the whole district in San Diego unified covers the whole city. And it was a challenge.
But I did win in the primary race to go into the general election. In the general election, my opponent was a nice lady, senior citizen who had a lot of knowledge of the political.
She was the staff of a state assemblyman. So she knew the ins and outs of that. And she had access to the assemblyman that she worked with and accessed his sources of income.
So I was outfunded significantly. Yet the school teachers endorsed me. So it was a close race. But I lost. And I did post-analysis of the election. It turned out that only 19% of the electorate had children in school.
And over 60% were senior citizens that participated in hot lunches at every school. They were more interested in hot lunches than in the education of children.
So the school rates had nothing to do with education. I wrongly focused on education, trying to open up the school opportunities for all, including those under serve.
So that's an avis for you running for a post thinking it was about education. When I missed the vote with the electorate.
And that's the unfairness of information in education. It's not even indistributed so that people are knowledgeable of how the system works.
And did you run for other offices?
The second office I ran was also for education at the community college level because the majority of underserved their first after graduate of high school.
Their next step is the community college, not a four year university. Because they can't afford it or they're not.
The community colleges are closer to them and more affordable. So I ran for the one, the southern most community college district that's adjacent to Tijuana. It's called Southwestern Community College.
I ran for that office. And before I decided to run, I pulled together Latino leaders throughout the area.
And they unanimously said they would support me. So I decided that I'd run because I had a base. They would support me.
And the majority of the ethnic groups were in Spanish, obviously in the South Bay, next to Tijuana.
Unfortunately, one of the professors got into some hot water in the district and he convinced his brother to run so that he would have a relative to defend him when he got because he was getting into trouble.
And this was after the promise of all the leaders that they were supporting. Well, the end result was that we had two Hispanics running in an angle, very wealthy from Coronado.
The district also, that's called Gerrymandering, included the wealthy, Anglos from Coronado, one of the wealthiest community in San Diego. That was part of the district.
And I was outspent again. And she was elected official from Coronado. So it was a close phrase. And the most voters voted for Hispanic, but there were two Hispanics.
And so I came in second. That was my second experience. That in the last time I ran was for City Council. I've been involved in redistricting. It's done every 10 years after the census count.
The enumeration changes districts because they come unbalanced through 10 years of growth. Their growth is not even. It's very uneven. And so you have to redraw lines to comply with the US Constitution of one person, one vote.
Really one person, not one man, but one person one vote. And you redistribute the so you draw lines. And I've been involved since 1980 in redistricting.
My first effort was redrawing the lines for the Stereo-California. For Stereo-Sembley and St. Ten years later, I was asked by the county chief administrator of officer to help him redraw the county lines.
So I served on the county redistricting. The next time there was a change of method of how people got selected to be and to make it less partisan or political.
So I asked the St. San Diego chose to have judges select commissioners to draw the lines. I was honored to be selected by judges to be redistricting the city of San Diego lines.
The most recent was the 2010 census and the city again had to redraw lines. The citizens of the Latino residents, San Diego, were being left out. And they created a Latino redistricting committee to shadow the work done by people appointed by the government.
And I was selected the chairman of the Latino redistricting committee. So we influenced the drawing and created for the first time a district that was majority Latino.
Latino residents, not voters, but it was Latino. And they've asked me to run. So I ran for the last time for city council.
I was also of the newly created 9th district. It was a new district because of the population growth in San Diego. And it was a Latino majority district, the 9th district tonight.
And the voter turnout was less than 10%. Those who could vote less than 10% turned out to vote.
And the voter turnout was less than 10% turned out to be the same. And the voter turnout was less than 10% turned out to be the same.
television every day as a newscaster.
Well known, nice lady.
And with so few people voting,
they went with name ID, a person who was already an incumbent
who was on their television sets every day.
And so I just, I've given my best shot
and that's the last time I ran.
So what are you working on now?
I, my wife and I, we own a business.
We, and it has, behind, you know, for being for profit,
it also has a social benefit to help, you know,
people that have difficulties.
In California, when somebody is in the office,
they're going to be like,
to help, you know, people that have difficulties.
In California, when somebody gets a driving under the influence,
when they get a citation, a ticket for driving under the influence,
especially for the second one,
they're required to put a breathalyzer in their car.
That's what we do.
We install breathalyzers in cars of people
that have been cited for driving under the influence.
And they're with us as a customer
until they serve their term.
And the length of time they're on depends on their situation.
The blood alcohol in the gutter, did they hurt anybody?
Did they do damage?
All the circumstances that could happen affect how long
they're with us as a customer.
But we see quite a few graduate, you know,
because we've been at it for half a dozen years.
And we represent the best manufacturer in the country.
They've been at it since it's a German company
that been at it since World War I.
As you know, gas was used in World War I.
So there were experts in gas.
As a matter of fact, there are the more suppliers of gas
in hospitals.
It were wide.
And they make those machines because they're based on
activation of gas breathalyzers.
And so we're providing a service.
And yet we're making a living.
We're still my wife and I.
She's also a business woman.
And she's the one that actually forced me to write the book,
my autobiography, Journey in Search of the American Dream,
because of her.
She says, you got to do it.
I had a grudgeful of files.
And you know, what are you going to do without what it's all this?
You know, all the walls with plaques and awards.
And it's just you got to write a book about it.
So I did.
With the help of the National Council,
like I said, they're permission to use and min on the board.
And a lot of the activities that I did
was the founders of the National Council.
As well as members, you know, when I was serving
for the maximum of two terms.
And I've done that with organizations.
I've never done anything by myself.
Does meaningful.
It's always with others.
And especially similar situated underserved populations.
That's what I'm about.
So maybe a last question.
When we talked a little bit before,
you're talking about immigration reform under Reagan.
Can you talk a little bit about where we are now
and your thoughts on especially immigration issues?
Well, the United States, although it's a country of immigrants,
the only native native Americans in the Piederns
were immigrants.
As a matter of fact, the Spaniards, the Spanish,
were here over 100 years before the Piederns arrived.
And other immigrants from other countries,
all over the world have come to this country.
We're a country of immigrants.
And we're proud out of it.
As a matter of fact, our constitution
spills out that we're all equal under the law.
And we all participate.
As a matter of fact, the French donated a statue
welcoming immigrants to this country.
Whether it be Irish from escaping the potato famine,
be the Italians, be the Irish, be the from South
and Central America, be the from Asia,
we're a country of immigrants.
That's our history.
That's what made this country great.
However, it's also a dynamic issue.
And things have changed over the years,
whereby it was open borders and welcoming everybody
to being in a little bit concerned that maybe they're
taking jobs away.
And nobody paid attention to the jobs they took
or they got, where jobs that people didn't want.
My first wife is from Oregon.
The few workers that were available to work
in the Willamette Valley and the Farms were immigrants
from Mexico.
Yet there were not enough immigrants.
You had strawberries rotting in the fields
because they were not enough.
As a matter of fact, the schools closed early.
So the children could go out in the fields and pick strawberries.
So they wouldn't be rotting in the fields.
People don't realize that they're creating jobs.
Immigrants are creating jobs.
They just think, sure, that over 80% of the farm work
in California is then by immigrants.
The Immigration Reform and Control Act that we did is to pardon those who are already
here.
Yes, I agree that there should be a regulated process
to how people come here and so forth.
But because we are immigrant.
As a matter of fact, research has shown
that immigrants contribute billions of dollars
to our economy and have invented developments
in our high-tech world and contributed significantly.
But yet they persist this concern, that A, they're taking jobs.
And now more recently, since we got involved in wars
in the Middle East, that there are people
that have hostile feelings are coming here
with that hostility from countries from Iran, Iraq,
other Saudi Arabia, other countries that may not
have friendly intentions.
That dimension adds to the mix of sentiment about immigrants.
As a matter of fact, one candidate, the Schrodinger
for President, is talking about building walls and deporting.
It's a debate.
It's an ongoing, fluctuating debate.
But my opinion is that we're a country of immigrants.
Yes, it makes sense that we should have a regulated process
so that it's a control to the extent that it's
absorbed, that's as needed by our economy, by our communities.
But we don't put walls.
That's not the reasonable, sensible way to purchase.
But yes, we should have some kind of regulated process
that we all have a voice to say about having the same policy
on how we manage that.
Thank you.
Any questions that I should have asked you today
or that you thought I might ask you that I didn't
or anything I should have asked you?
Well, I'm honored and pleased that you've taken the time
to talk to me and about sharing my experiences
in terms of what the intent of Congress was
in terms of sharing the contributions of folks
with different backgrounds that have been ignored over the years.
The way I like to learn a little bit more about the end product
in terms of the distribution of that and how we can make it
more accessible to, because as I said before,
education is really what opens the eyes,
opens the minds of folks that don't have a full understanding
of our complete society and not like to know how we can get it
into the hands of those that need it that should get
full enlightened and be more informed of the contributions
of other folks that have done that maybe not speak their language
or live in their neighborhoods, but are here to contribute
to make this country greater.
I think that's a great point when we can talk about that.
So that's what I'm interested in.
That's why I agreed to participate.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History
and Culture.